Oh welcome back to the Jenna Dewan hot
town feels so good to be back here he
does we haven't been here last week we
did in podcast because of the car I said
we were in so we do apologize so much
for that
we are back we're healthy week before
that never an even here because you're
practicing at Ober so we have okay yeah
for almost three weeks I know and I was
just in Iowa and Julian was just in
Austin so we also haven't seen each
other I know for days this is podcast I
know I missed you so much
this amazing podcast is brought to you
by the amazing sponsor of me undies guys
I'm currently wearing them show it off
real quick oh my god I love me some
Andy's have got Bob go to me undies
accomplice Jenna Jillian right now and
you get 20% off your first order guys me
undies three times softer than cotton it
has been proved with their micro modal
fabric Michael on on amazingly cool
designs I don't need to say anything
more but I will later go get yourself
some mayonnaise right now Mandy's calm /
annejulien other sponsor this week is
texture you can start reading all your
favorite magazines in one convenient
place on your smartphone tablet or
computer with the texture app go to
texture calm slash Jenna Jillian and you
can get a free trial right now all your
favorite magazines guys good texture
thank you to our sponsor Thank You
sponsors yes so it is Sunday it is the
day before you were watching this
welcome to the past how does the future
well yeah I just I got home today from
Austin Jenna got home last night from
Iowa Iowa you were going to be far away
I'm good we have these arms so I can I
know but people get so mad at you when
you touch your mic cuz it's like
non-stop you know sometimes you can I'll
just lean forward know what's worse
touching your mic nuns up or being like
hey how's it going I don't mind that I'm
not like an audience I am it doesn't it
doesn't bother me I don't really care
that much I know
sorry anyway yeah I had a good time uh I
did the live Q&A at Iowa it was rowdy
and rad as [ __ ] and thank you guys for
having me
and I hope you enjoyed yourselves if you
were there and if not hopefully I will
meet you someday soon but you did like
Julien like shot a behind the scenes
stuff for a music video yeah there's
awesome shot behind the scenes for a
band called Midland in Austin Texas I
was a new single called drinking problem
it was so fun it was so fun I've been
you know getting myself more involved in
these types of jobs where I have
creative control we're sort of directing
a video but and I'm not part of it like
it's been so exciting to do stuff like
that and so this trip was just
exceptionally fun and you were with
rome's husband Colin my good buddies and
business partner call you often you're
like lost-soul twins we are we are yeah
we're two peas in a pod
so we had a we had an absolute blast
being in Austin and hanging out but we
also it was cool because we work really
well together and it's not often you
find someone who who you work well with
but yes I mean we we basically were
there for for three and a half days and
we shot two full days on set and yeah I
mean we were just with the band the
whole time and we went to a bunch of
different old honky-tonk bars and around
Texas like we went to forget something
Rock forget the name in this town [ __ ]
I'll remember later but we went to these
lake towns outside of Austin and what's
all these bars and it was really cool
seeing all these locations for real like
I had never been to that part of Texas
before but did it make you want to move
to Austin more or less more no you don't
even know like my level I was not
refilled because we every time I go to
Austin the level of wanting to move
there goes all the way
slowly it fades back down and then mines
been refilled I know but I missed you
people are asking for you people were
asking for you in Austin tell them what
that person said to you in the checkout
line oh yeah I was in a housing Whole
Foods in Austin apparently the first
Whole Foods ever really yeah that's what
Colin said but I don't anything Colin
says you have to beware because you
might be [ __ ] with you but apparently
it was the first of all foods ever
anyway it was a beautifully giant
amazing all foods I'm standing in the
register and the person helping the
customer next to me in the checkered
like he's standing within 5 feet of me
doesn't say anything all time and then
randomly he just goes or the other and I
just start dying laughing so funny was
about as funny like preceded by like oh
hey man is gone what's in it no it was
just like is that it reishi I don't
think I was here where she a doctor what
she's just uh she's already eating some
cookie dough
yeah you know that's really cool though
but what was the weather like in Iowa
her fast was it cold
um it wasn't that cold at all it was
sort of like you know high of 60s low
40s like a little chilly at night or not
yeah but we were we were only there for
like a tiny bit so it didn't matter
yeah and you meet up was there your
thing was inside yeah obviously Rome was
freezing
obviously Rome does not even had a pact
for cold weather yeah we were talking
about on the on the way back when we
were driving how you guys like weather
and the girls driving the car both
agreed that you guys like novelty
weather you like feeling cold for a
couple of days or whatever and then
leaving because you don't realize how
much it sucks your soul out year after
year for like months at a time yeah I
mean that's accurate I've never claimed
to like weather every day in my life I
just enjoy it when we go to places that
have actual weather and I go away that's
novelty weather okay you don't need to
diminish it I just like when it snows
and I'm not at home - fair enough
um but I miss you I miss you I don't do
well without you because we just miss
you you never been away from each other
Oh gross woman's last time we were gone
from each other
I know
while ago I was the gross part of the
podcast but also it was like a little
traumatic because it was the first time
for me that I had been in a car on the
highway since the accident and you know
we take the same way to and from the
airport you have to get on the 405
really only one way and I mean it's
weird it sucks it's not a feeling and
when you drive by that spot
I had like almost I was like triggered a
little bit I was like we were driving
home today and I just took like a cold
deep breaths and calls like what's wrong
I was like I just hate this spot yes we
got an accident it's like it's hard man
it's so weird feeling it so we're
feeling but you can't like I'm proud of
us for even you know a few days like as
soon as you were good enough to drive
because my legs still haven't [ __ ] but
like we got in the car like you have to
carry on with your life like you can't
let it develop into some you know
anxious phobia type situation like it's
only been what two weeks about 14 total
days and we are both in cabs separately
away from each other are you worth
calling again on the 405 coming back the
same way and you just you know just do
it get over with and get over it you
know so but it's not fun but we did it
it's honestly you're right and it's what
weird thing is like I wouldn't say you
know before the accident that I was like
a bad driver or a fast driver
I just wasn't super defensive and slow
and now I like I can't even explain how
real the change has been like for me at
least just being in a car whether or not
I'm driving like I feel different but I
don't feel comfort like it's it's like
it's like when you know someone someone
makes you flinch ten times and then they
punch you the eleventh time and then
you're like whoa like it really happened
like I actually like I need a flinch now
I really need a flinch you know what I
mean yeah and so now I'm in the car and
I feel like every time there's a stop
ahead and people aren't paying attention
like it's like Oh what like this this is
real I know it's like it's very rare or
whatever to get an accident but we
experienced it on such a level that I I
feel like it's changed the way I Drive
and the way I feel inside of a car
well I mean selfishly I'm really happy
that it changed the way that you drive
because I was in high school and gotten
an accident someone t-boned me because
they ran a red light like the person in
front of me had already cleared through
the intersection that's how badly they
ran the red light and I always would
like you wouldn't get like in fights or
anything but I would tell Julian to like
slow down or whatever and I am convinced
that you know if you've never been in a
car accident that you drive differently
you know you don't know why you should
flinch
there's no reason yeah well yeah I mean
two different people different things
you know maybe it doesn't take a car
accident for someone to drive very
carefully I'm not saying now you're
absolutely right you did have that
experience a lot right which is why I
always always like Julian can you please
like me just cuz I've just always been
that way I Drive you know this on the
right side all the time slow lane when
there's traffic I literally have a party
for myself my mind because that's the
speed that I like to travel at you know
I don't like to go fast I don't I don't
I just don't like it
I'm selfishly happy that you have a new
perspective on driving and that you know
every time you get behind the wheel it's
not you you can't trust it's everybody
[ __ ] else and and even you can't
trust your equipment you can't trust
your car all the time you know it's just
a million different things could go
wrong and happen and so it's good to be
hyper aware of how serious it is anytime
you're in a car so I'm glad and I'm glad
that were okay obviously yeah yeah it
was it was a weird couple weeks but
we're okay and I just want to say a huge
thank you to all you guys for the
support you've been outpouring get wells
and wonderful messages yeah it's really
fun incredible so it means I mean it's
like the average Joe gets in an accident
and their family and friends are like it
well and then everything's back to
normal but for us it was like we had all
you guys telling us get well get well I
don't know were you doing today like
it's nice you guys are long really
really sweet yeah but enough about the
Carson because that shit's dead and gone
with true oh yeah and then this week
we're I'm going to be at vloggerfair
Jenn's coming with me we're going to go
to Seattle for luggage smooth fun
I've never been to see out of my life me
either as much as I'm like ready to just
kind of be at home because we just
traveled I'm also excited everything
would be cool yeah yeah so we got that
coming up and uh yeah but so we wanted
to just kind of like Chaffey for for a
second with you guys about what's going
on with us because we miss you we need
to update you but we also have a game
that we want to play yes with the
election coming up tomorrow is election
day the 8th right it's uh I'm trying to
rattle through my brain what day it is
and the my day just goes up and what
doesn't
whatever with the election literally
around the corner we thought a fun thing
to do since I mean a lot of people are
nervous they're stressed and you know
everything's kind of intense right now
it has been for some time you know what
a fun thing to do would be is to just
like how we did a nuclear winter except
we were to make them about the
presidential candidates so the rules are
as follows you're going to strip away
everything that you know about the
candidates we have Donald Trump Hillary
Clinton Gary Johnson and Jill Stein
strip away everything about them
political parties are just names they're
just naming the purpose of this game on
Tuesday they are not just names and do
not base your vote on this game I doubt
anyone would ever um and then we are
going to pull out because we wrote your
equalities it's similar nuclear mental
qualities and also like policies because
the president okay and this is the old
like we're going to pull out four
qualities put them in front of one of
these four people and then we have four
qualities we have to decide based on
that alone who would become the
president of the United States so we
have to erase all of our preconceived
notions and all of our previous
knowledge of these people as they are
now just names with new they're getting
new qualities they're being reborn in
form of ding fam yeah because when [ __ ]
gets weird let's just make a game and
laugh about it yes good mono hell yeah
that's how I live my life that's a
really cute one thing I got to say thank
you oh I'm benefits sent it to me that's
awesome they're really [ __ ] nice to
me man I don't know why they're so
[ __ ] nice to me why why would
somebody nice you because you're a
wonderful amazing beautiful person I did
like one event with them a couple years
ago what thank you yes they know we're
with dr. Wu with the tattoos I remember
that yeah like he was doing tat free
tattoos for people and I was there doing
like I'm angry and then ever since then
much trouble that brow stuff and like
they just really do love you like I was
really [ __ ] nice route package it was
like there was a lot of love in that
package the way they put that together
it was really sweet yeah it was really
nice
all right finally ready like that you
guys are just nice [ __ ] people man
and it literally they sent me this
onesie and they were like get well soon
I know that's just made me want to cry
my [ __ ] eyes out yeah all right all
right enough of this a penis oh all
right let's go you pick first
all right so this is going to trump this
is gonna go to Trump I fold them up very
tiny because I wanted to like shake it
and have them rattle around okay for
Donald Trump you can only vote if you're
subscribed to his YouTube channel all
right so if you would how many people
are in the United States you know the
answer to that so that I do not come how
many people are in the United States
nope
how many people are in the United States
the population of United States is about
324 million damn all right yeah I just
got past like oh my god you would have
300 million subscribers 20 million damn
okay for Hillary she forces veganism on
everyone in the United States oh okay
all right Gary Johnson will impose a
50-hour soda and candy tax oh that's
brutal
looks like every bag of Skittles you
want cost like $52 and soda tell you
that would make that would that would
probably honestly effect do you think
that would affect like obesity like
taxing really really bad foods for you I
mean that's a theory they've tried to do
that with tobacco and all the way to get
big food it's true okay Jill Stein is
big Lee sex addicted I like that you
made me I think I forced him to write
big Lee sex addictively sex addicted
okay I'm gonna say that we have to get
rid of Hillary for this because you
can't have a president the forces
everyone to be vegan you know the
president forces everyone to do anything
but just think of all the businesses
that would like it go out of business if
you did it overnight you mean okay the
businesses that we're going to business
is the farthest thing I worried about
the the thing is faulty rioting like
that's what I'm saying right right but
okay so you have to imagine the people
aren't writing because they can't eat
cheeseburgers you shut down someone's
hamburger restaurant like I would riot
[ __ ] I'm saying overnighting the amount
of people who enjoy meat and animal
products throughout the United States
which is a ton I get that are gonna
literally lose their [ __ ] minds if
you outlaw no I get that I get the
business owners earning me mad but the
believe I'm saying you can be upset
about not having a choice of what to eat
but once you start [ __ ] people's
livelihoods that's what's going to make
it so people riot fair enough I think a
violent riot
I still think violent riots will come
from people not allowed to have cheese
but do you think people take that [ __ ]
so insane letters as they should it's
you take away their ability to earn a
living
so we're saying we get rid of Hillary
you agree on that yeah that can
all right I think Harry Johnson is a
good bet for this one because I don't
think a lot of people uh know what
YouTube channels are and how to
subscribe to one and a lot of people
want to vote so that's that's difficult
one to employ the Trump thing I'm
leaning towards Gary Johnson the Jill is
just a scandal waiting to happen I'm not
following you so you're saying you you
think that Gary Johnson should be the
next president because this is the least
is the it's the king of the [ __ ] so
if you go to the movies you could spend
$200 that's already what you spend at
the movies all candy think about
Halloween what would happen on Halloween
you don't have to pay taxes you just
have to buy Halloween candy but no
that's not what that says I know I just
added
I just think Gary is the best bet yeah
but like what's the problem with jail
being big lease exadata [ __ ] everyone in
her but that's her choice yeah but it
just it makes it the us look terrible as
Chris channels all of what she really
impeached
what if she's really good at her job but
just like needs to have sex every hour
on the hour
what if Gary Johnson is really good at
his job he just made you pay $4 for soda
fair enough that's not candle we're
getting rid of this person that needs
you to subscribe to their YouTube
channel like what if they put garbage on
it all the time but like you can't vote
at all if you're not subscribed in order
to vote against him you'd still have to
subscribe to you as you do yeah let's
get rid of over by don't just sneeze oh
[ __ ] oh okay
alright so we got Gary and Jill what's
wrong with being Bigley sex addicted it
would be entertaining and the soda tax
might cause riots Bigley sex addicted
some point it has to interfere with her
job it just has to all right I'm going
with Jill I'm going Gary I'm going with
Jill okay good for you
okay so every round we vote and then at
the end we vote on her ass up around
high to back thing I think we settled on
the name Gary come on you were the one
that said the judge now I think about it
there will be riots and I don't like
riots for candy and soda people take
that crap seriously fine
Jill's our new president she's big Lee
sex addicted and we love her Babli
weakly are you ready welcome Jill sign
the news president of United sex of them
I mean States of America Stein tight
she was lucky when everyone around her
oh good for her Sara body president
themed pornos would be off the chain oh
hell yes all right so we're gonna do the
round number two the big she's big Lise
accident
all right so strip those away round
number two is going on
we got Jill Stein says that every male
needs to enlist in the army for at least
five years at the age of sixteen oh okay
Donald Trump will abolish guns and
replace them all with flamethrowers
that's so productive okay all right Gary
Johnson
well Gary Johnson can't read English
like he's gonna document us to sign and
then just read it to him they can read
it he can read other languages but
cannot read in the teens speaking fine
and understand it he just can't read it
reading is a weird disorder okay Hillary
thinks pro-choice means your
professional choice maker all right mom
so I'm gonna go out on a limb here and
say Jill Stein that that ain't going to
happen
no everyone like so as soon as you're 16
you just get drafted into them so then
our military is nice
I know the male population at the age of
16 yeah anyone know that's not gonna
work
yeah she's gone she's gone i jealous
go back to being sexist a big little
Jackson okay can we have a president who
can't read English though like he can't
even read the teleprompter and his
speeches oh yeah it had to be like in
the French and then we have to translate
it in his mind so I've come out like
broken translated English no what if he
said it in French first and then
translated himself like Jack well he's
his own translator or what is that guys
in the UFC comes and translate his
speeches yeah I don't think we can have
a president they can't read English
let's just hold on I'm pretty good
pro-choice means that you're a
professional choice maker that's really
crazy [ __ ] bad yeah and know what
pro-choice I know these are like short
sentences but we have to assume if she
thinks this what psychology is not
qualified Oh Hillary you're gone Hillary
you're gone girl I've got a flamethrower
thing I mean first of all we can I just
have a question guys but logistically
yeah who is manufacturing billions of
flame furnace because there are so many
guns in the United States and there are
not so many flavors wait so you think he
can't read English we still love him the
worst part about this is that he can't
read his favorite magazines on texture
oh my god even if he goes to texture
calm / to the Julian right now he can't
see can't get a free trial and read all
of his favorite magazines from Men's
Health Men's Fitness Bloomberg billboard
Business Weekly all he's amazing he just
looks at the pictures though you can
actually read the articles and see the
awesome content that all your favorite
magazines have
guys texture is super convenient they've
reimagined magazines giving you articles
and stories that you really want you
don't have to sift through the magazine
they will recommend stories and even new
magazines for you based on what you've
read at scale the team yeah it's awesome
I have a team curating for you it's like
I said there's all the magazine's you'd
need Bon Appetit
Esquire essence I mean anything you're
into they have and you don't have to
waste your time with outdated magazines
get it on here and get a new texture app
and get going
start binge reading your magazines for
free at texture comm slash annejulien
with a free trial that you get from
being a dink fan member and let us know
how you like it those like that's the
greatest thing about this app is they
have something for you whatever you're
into they're going to have it in the
form of a magazine on texture so breeze
through hundreds of your favorite
magazines including back issues and pick
the articles that interest you the most
check it out a texture contrast
channeling right now also get yourself
some neon ease because you know what
it's it's the season for giving and you
should give yourself immunities because
they're crazy comfortable three times
softer than cotton you don't understand
what that means until you've felt it
because it is crazy soft mm-hmm and
another thing about these manatees is
they freakin last I bought underwear
that just does not last that munities is
like I don't know how they do it but
they build it so durable and so
comfortable that you can wear these over
and over and over and over and never
watch them I'm just kidding God they
just last goodness for the price of two
cocktails Mandy's will deliver your new
favorite pair of underwear right to your
doorstep try them on if they're not the
most comfortable best feeling uneasy
Vera had they will refund you and let
you keep your first pair for free
included in the price is a sweet touch
of modal a special fabric three times
the softest cotton proven which is
really awesome so for a limited time
everyone in the dink fan will get 20%
off their first order by going to meet
andis comm slash Jenna Julianne that's
me and he's a comm slash Jenna and
Julianne thank you so much
responsibility guys and you guys are so
supportive for letting us do whatever we
want
that's pretty [ __ ] great pretty cool
you guys are rad yeah you guys need to
remember any sponsor that we have on
this show is down with
the dink nests like we agreed before
they ever know what's up like yeah you
guys can just do whatever guys it crazy
and cool and stupid really
Thank You Man all right sound great so
far we've had Jill Stein who is Bigley
sex addicted and Gary Johnson who cannot
read English so is our to president yes
third party candidates both ways
all right truck no no that is all you do
with anything you know I'm just saying
okay Donald Trump uh will keep gay
marriage legal but gay divorce is
punishable by death it makes you laugh
so hard like you're allowed to get gay
married but you cannot get gay divorce
like it's like they love gay merge so
much that they wanted to work out
miserable by death all right
hi dad Jill Stein we'll get rid of all
states merge with Mexico and Canada and
make a super country called it's fine I
like that Oh down with that all right
Hillary Clinton yells yeehaw
at the end of every sentence okay all of
these people I would be down with saying
that I for some reason think Hillary's
voice ay mija which is aa
Gary Johnson is a hyper conspiracy okay
all right this is a good one because I
personally think the conspiracy thing is
terribly dangerous but so juicy and it
may be amazing the best four years of my
life okay look first of all let's talk
about the fact that Jill Stein wants to
make a super country like immediately
once she gets like she already has the
groundwork laid let's assume like she
has a plan and she gets elected and damn
it happens right so it's Canada and
Mexico right Mexico are all blah
my country super country us it gets
renamed and there's also no more states
no more states everything is everything
it's a part of all our called it's fine
I am talking about that no I am about
that no I'll tell you why I'm about cats
I'm about that one really specific
stupid reason why I tried something
called Moscow have you heard of that no
I tried something called mass Cal in
Austin this weekend for the first time
ever and it it's very similar to tequila
because it comes from the agave plant
but it is not tequila it's its own class
of liqueur called mass cow and boy is
that [ __ ] delicious ok and it comes from
Mexico so we get all the masks al it's
not it's okay we'll show you how to
taste them you're gonna vote for Jill
hey in this election
hey right now hey what first of all
that's very exciting to me that there's
a new class of liquor but I did not know
exactly I just didn't know that well I
mean think about it cuz I've said this
about instruments before like how come
there's no one making new Engstrom I
want a new internal instrument how can
we only have like vodka tequila like
somebody make me a new liquor mask
that's very exciting
it's we gotta try I gotta show it
fortunately Julian that is the dumbest
reason I've ever heard to abolish all
states and make one super country called
it's fine I'm the game it's fine it's
fine it'll be fine it's fine it's not
fine but like when you think that we
have just enough time as a country of
our size bottle one government now
imagine there's no state governments
there's only one fact let's just maybe
her I'll turn her sideways that's a
maybe let's go to Gary this is a
definitely problem we're keeping him in
the hyper conspiracy theorist sustained
Hillary and her yeehaw stick ass isn't
the worst thing in the world literally
it is so annoying
if you imagine her saying something
super serious :
Oh God a thoughts and prayers are with
the people that we just lost yeehaw
jennife end everyone okay bye
she's so she has no chiller II know
chiller okay Donald Trump keeps gay
marriage legal but gay divorce is Pasha
what I know I usually like the word
punishable by death in the same sentence
gay I don't like no that's terrible you
can't have that No
welcome our new President of the United
States hyper conspiracy theory we need
him on the podcast ASAP no like okay so
if he was president I would be the
youtuber to go to the White House and
talk to him cuz I'd be like how [ __ ]
yell yet no but like so think about this
NASA is like hey we're thinking about uh
you know sending some people to Mars and
he's like guys Mars alright let me just
tell you a bunch of stuff about Mars
okay first of all there's people in the
moon that are gonna be watching us
second of all we can't build a spaceship
out of this anymore we gotta build out
of pure gold okay and you guys got a fun
just trust me on this he gets a
presidential election and he does the
inaugural address and he's like I just
want to thank you guys for finally
electing someone that's not part of
lizard people
he's like partner while he's running
he's like I'm gonna do everything that I
can to break into the Library of
Congress to like go all the way around
the White House and figure out all the
secrets and tell them all we're all like
yeah expose yourself
he's like first thing I'm doing is
making it so anyone can go inside of
area 51 anytime they like in fact I'm
gonna go there right now yes okay so all
right good one I really like that okay I
was from cotton oh man I didn't expect
this game to be quite so fun it's pretty
fun I didn't expect it in okay Donald
Trump will make the US official religion
Scientology all non-believers have to go
to a camp or get put to death so what
camp like a big camp where you learn how
to be a Scientologist but now I go fun
camp know like a click good
concentration camp all right keep going
Jill Stein enforces a strict 9:00 p.m.
curfew Oh brutal like nationwide curfew
but not only not only for kids look for
everyone yeah
for everyone so you can't work past 9:00
p.m. either so technically that
everything should be empty on the
streets and yes I kind of like that
because that would be cool like shoot
armed we can go out and shoot like empty
freeways and stuff at 9:00 p.m. you know
you can't the curfew knock Hillary is
part of a child sex ratio we will get to
that Gary Johnson will make it so it's
illegal to dance yeah he's on a weird
Street right now I think this game was
gonna be this yeah this games game okay
so we have the US official religion is
Scientology part of us you know like
what the [ __ ] we got some [ __ ]
candidates strict 9:00 p.m. curfew and
Larry and Jill are like in the same
school of thought of trying to like
control the people okay well okay Gary
and Joe how come it's always Gary Jill
we haven't had one dollar Hillary oh is
this a sign oh my god so these in my
opinion Gary jeweler far less serious
than you have to go to a Scientology
camp or die or sex ratio of a child
secretary get rid of both of them we
have to we have to we really do so the
dancing thing I kind of like that
because I feel like dancing would evolve
so much more if it was illegal you know
okay
well correct me if I'm wrong because I
explained this to Julianne earlier
because this is what I thought it was
illegal at some point in Ireland to
dance which is why they have their arms
down in those Ireland or Scotland
Ireland okay so when the Irish dancing
and all that hot like got formed that's
why your arms are super straight down
would dance with just their feet so that
if someone saw them from window they
wouldn't be able to tell that they were
dancing right which is blew my mind I
mean that's wrong
that's wrong um but that's why I wrote
that one I didn't think it would be that
funny I'm thinking of someone being like
it's illegal to dance whatever it
wouldn't be the worst thing in the world
plus like it'd be incredibly difficult
to enforce he's kind of go hand in hand
though like a 9:00 p.m. curfew like
think about that there's no bars like
imagine all the jobs that would have to
be deleted yeah no one would everyone
lose their job who works a night we got
to go with the dancing all right
gentlemen welcome you new president can
you imagine how funny that would be
though like if you just like you went
somewhere and all of a sudden you're
like and they're like you sure yeah or
not that was a tight move that you just
did that you're under arrest
like think of Albany videos would go
viral from someone just like dancing
really good so funny
that'd be amazed so funny all right that
was a good bet that was gay all right
how many more do we have our we have two
more rounds two more rounds Norris has
so far has Gary been president the most
I think Gary has yeah I think he's won
three or four times and Joe's won one
all right all right let me go auto
versus ped Jill Stein doesn't believe in
jails or prisons and wants to abolish
them ooh crazy okay
like that would just like overnight
though she'd be like everyone is free
now well that's the thing if you want to
delve into this like idea is she haven't
does have an alternate solution or she
just literally free no she's literally
freeing all of them and then no one
would go to jail or prison ever again so
it's the purge every day
yeah maybe okay Donald Trump can only
count to 40 okay all right okay Gary
refuses every means of transportation
except getting individually airlifted to
wherever he's going by attaching himself
to six drones I like that guy I like his
I like the cut of his jib that was yours
you wrote that okay that I am
mm-hmm Hillary Clinton will create a
wage gap for left and right handed
people yes I enjoy that actually I don't
know if I enjoy it because I don't know
where which way the way to Apple yeah
yeah we didn't specify yeah
you could either end up like getting
paid a lot more or a lot less for your
job yeah oh yeah then you're gonna find
all these like bootlegging right-handed
people who are fake for or the other day
yeah yeah we're vice-versa
all right so I definitely think the Jill
Stein needs to go because I'm getting an
anxious thinking about that yeah okay
no no prisons that doesn't work yeah
that would be the purge every day yeah
okay um so now we have someone who can
only count to 40
he's Hillary's gonna create a wage gap
right and left-handed people and someone
I say we get rid of Hillary because I
don't want another wage gap by right
with Gary Gary refuses to go anywhere
unless he's carelessly the same guy in
every round okay that's kind of weird
but relatively harmless
he's like flying around with his drugs
like conspiracy don't care you're just
saying it's believed Hillary
okay Donald John Kelly counterparty how
does he read through tax puzzle and he's
like Oh hmm that the 12% oh I don't know
what that number is it's 41 I don't know
what it is well if he can only count to
40 what makes you think he understands
percentages well yeah I mean by the
logic of not being able to count the 40
he's probably not fit to be here in your
country wait so he doesn't know how old
he is either he's lost count
ever since he turned 40 he doesn't know
any time someone tried to explain it
they just come up empty okay Johnson I
like him I like it again really Gary
Johnson early please welcome Gary
Johnson the president United States who
refuses every means of transportation
except getting individually airlifted to
whether he's going by being attached to
himself by six drones but I mean here's
the thing about that first of all we eat
what this country would develop some
insanely cool drugs second of all the
battery technology would have to advance
so fast cuz he's if he's flying around
those batteries can't last 30 minutes
they got a last couple hours I'm down
with that
thank you Gary Johnson wow this is tight
all right
last round last wrench are you going ah
you got okay hold on give me so I can
open it Donald Trump huh let's see
enforces literal i 4i punishment so sir
gosh so like if you steal something off
like if you you kill someone you get
killed
yeah like if you rape someone they might
like mutilate your genitals yeah or they
matches rape you
oh wow okay my like American Horror
Story yeah okay can Jill Stein will make
pedophilia legal [ __ ] a okay that's
not a really light note guys right okay
Hillary Clinton will make gas free if
you're wondering who's paying for it
it's fine I like that I like that
because it's fine like you don't get too
worried about it
no come on bring prohibition [ __ ] damn
it he Lana's down okay he let us down
okay um like we have to get rid of Jill
and Donald Trump we can't have someone
that enforces a literal i4i punishment
or makes pedophilia illegal right bye
so Hillary is gonna make gas free or
Gary Johnson's gonna bring prohibition
back huh here's the thing I've never
been to a speakeasy
and I kind of want to go to one I mean
write me a secret little bar we have to
have a passcode and that's kind of tight
any tight bass oh well like really the
holism in America would probably go down
a lot you never known I know lot of
people are just sitting around making
moonshine which can like just make you
10 billion times drunker
if it's like is that right as I'm making
the moonshine if you're making like
homemade like grain alcohol and she will
really [ __ ] you oh yeah it's not about
being homemade it's just about grain
alcohol being grain alcohol it's
literally [ __ ] poison it will [ __ ]
you up faster I don't think I'm making
it but that's what happens when you like
ferment fruit yes if you're making like
really hardcore alcohol that's like they
should they do in prison right yeah yeah
so that's what people would do but there
was prohibition so everyone right but
when you said like I think alcoholism
would go down I kind of disagree because
if you're making your own do you think
everyone would just suddenly make their
own moves all the time a lot of people a
lot of people but not everyone who
drinks and is well maybe then anyone
those predisposed to being an alcoholic
that started drinking homemade like just
[ __ ] harder to do true also the music
video that we were seeing BTS the
concept of the video is that they're
their moonshine bootleggers and they're
selling their moonshine to pay for this
like you know what their band or
whatever but I kind of like the idea of
prohibition I think that's cool I don't
I don't like the I don't like that you
wrote this one yeah my gas free and if
you're wondering who's paying for it
it's fine
CNG is the thing I don't like about that
if that's her policy what's her other
policy gonna be like oh we probably
won't go to war it's fine don't worry
about it like well really though if you
make gas free for everyone in the United
States you have no explanation
what's going on ladies and gentlemen
every round great how did it happen this
is totally random because this is too
sketchy
this is way too square how did you win
like literally almost every round I
don't know it must have just we mixed
him up I don't know well I mean nothing
was great in this round like it was a
lose-lose as loosely as list but lives
win lose lose lose win it's a three loss
one win lose I mean hopefully that took
some of the stress out of your day or
stress that you have about the election
because we're just here to have fun you
know it's like uh it's in in Parks and
Rec she
running against Paul Rudd and he's like
really dumb and he's I think they're I
asking his stance on abortion and he's
like my stance on abortion is uh let's
just all have a good time that's what is
the right of the oh why did you clean
that up so neatly it looks so nice I
like it
alright Gary's the winner that was
really fun that was fun we should figure
out different ways to do the this game
for other things because this yeah we
fun yell is fun good podcast hell yeah
thank you guys for hanging out for
another podcast make sure you check out
the sponsors and uh we will see you next
week for another one and we love you
very much
uh please vote in you know just it's
fine it'll be you know guys if you're
stressed out about so decide it's fine
for the record Julian started saying
that in Austin about everything it's
right it's right
I mean anytime things start to take a
toll on you in life and you know it's
fine it's it's it's fine okay that's
that's all enough of that
thanks for watching big town we love you
yeah